obviously like i watched jay aubry as
well because i mean he's i think jlb is
good friends with uh right opinion yeah
i
can tell you how they help each other
out their styles are like similar but
different enough that uh you know their
content stands out for themselves but
i've just i kind of respect their
content in the same way where yeah
they really know how to break down like
how the
how public perception can warp an
opinion of a certain person
i think i think sometimes coming to your
channels i don't like being told what my
opinion should be
yeah and i feel like sometimes some
narration like i think some videos in
jailbreak like very like they kind of
like i mean the
way he narrates would be like all right
you should think this way i'm sure he
doesn't intend to that's just the way i
like perceived it but i mean still
amazing videos
yeah it's either one way or the other
where if commentary channels either
i know you're a [ __ ] clown and i know
no one's gonna [ __ ] listen to you
yeah like you know something like
keemstar you know what yeah yeah
like it's it's it's either one way or
the other well it's like so many
commentary channels i see
that hit that middle ground and you know
try
and think that they are like the [ __ ]
holy grail of opinions yeah where it's
just like dude it's just
and then and then you have some
commentary channels uh that just kind of
our commentary channels like technically
speaking but just the way that they
present [ __ ] and like the topics they
choose just
kind of go away from commentary like
perfect example that i [ __ ] love
watching is leon lush
i like me yeah but more more humor
focused i think yeah
but technically he's a commentary
channel right
technically speaking but like the way he
presents it and the topics he covers is
just like
just so it's like cody ko right with
like the the
what's the series that he does where he
cringes that [ __ ] i think he's just
called cringe right
i don't really watch cody kell that's
the other guy curtis connor is it the
other one that's like those three right
yeah cause i i i don't really watch them
i watch a lot of uh i really like danny
gonzalez i think he's really funny um
i think also the stuff he does where he
like bought uh this video he made where
he's got like 15 000
on youtube ads that was such a funny
moment oh i think i've seen that video
i was like i didn't know who you're
talking about but i remember yeah
just such a good personality yeah yeah
yeah yeah and drew garden as well
obviously
yeah have you heard of the channel
called anxiety war
no no i i mentioned it briefly he he
basically does how to catch a predator
like that's his thing right right he's a
[ __ ] psychopath like
i don't know how you can he spends all
day talking to pedophiles i don't know
how you can do that like how do you do
that that's weird right yeah that is
weird
but like he goes and meets up with them
and like films them and some of these
dude there's one dude he met up with
that was like eight foot or some [ __ ]
this guy's built like a brick [ __ ] house
and he turned up trying to be a girl
what yeah yeah and so he goes up he
literally just knows how to catch a
predator but instead of going there with
like
armed police yeah yeah he goes alone
with like a camera and i'm like you're
insane you die
or anything no no it's just it's just he
turns up the handheld camera how many
subscribers does he have
oh god like over half a million it's
like it's like chris hanson hard mode
yeah yeah and like at one point i think
yeah i think one of the one time the
predator one of the predator
the flower the other predators tried to
sue him one of them did it worked out
but
like the guy's got a strange personality
as well when you're watching him i'd
watch it just for fascination just to
see how this guy does it but man it's
such a weird presenting style and he's
constantly like giggling to himself
while he's recording it
it's really weird yeah it's it's an
interesting watch i don't think it's
like
it's something unnerving about watching
it because the content that he's talking
about and the way that he's talking
about like he's talking about like
how he trolled someone on xbox but it's
actually somebody who's trying to [ __ ] a
kid and it's like
okay kind of seeing a pattern with all
the
all the content you're recommending and
it is very much you just like
the human aspect the human kind of story
behind it right
there's a lot of channels that i like
that i just think the guys are [ __ ]
weirdo and i don't
really like the personality but yeah
they're just so fascinating to watch i
reckon you'd love this channel then uh
that aki recently recommended me called
soft white underbelly
that sounds familiar yeah they've all
heard of that channel it's this guy who
basically he's like this photographer
guy but he basically goes around
like streets of la and stuff like that
and he picks up like homeless people for
whatever reason and
they bring him in to interview them and
kind of like talk about their life and
like why they're homeless and how they
got there and [ __ ] like that so like
there's ones where he's like you know he
like he picks up a dude like from the
street
and like asks what he's about and he
ended up being homeless because he was
he like
raped his mom or something or like did
something like this like insane crime
and
these people just like [ __ ] break
down on camera just talking about their
life and it's just yeah
it's really raw but it's so [ __ ]
interesting to watch just because
you otherwise would never hear about
these people's lives right yeah and
there's like no [ __ ] like
there's no like you know snarky like
commentator being all like presenter
being like so tell us your story about
where you're homeless
this is so it's just like it's literally
just listening to
a dude try and communicate with this
clearly broken person for whatever
reason and you just
some of these backstories i'm just like
holy [ __ ] like
how are you alive yeah it's so 50 50 for
me with those especially when they're
getting homeless people because i'm like
it's such a fine line between
in my eyes being like genuine or just
like
taking advantage well like this is like
kind of like reality tv yeah you know
what i mean like
it's kind of like the um i don't know
the backstory olympics you know and yeah
right yeah yeah yeah where it's just
like okay who has the worst
most tragic backstory who do we want to
cheer for right more yeah
i'm always like okay some of them like i
could definitely see god there was a
channel where like this guy
interviews like meth heads and stuff i
can't remember the name of the top of my
head but that's a really good channel
yeah he did like really raw emotional
yeah i feel i feel like like with the
way that you present like i've seen a
bunch of his
videos and they all seem pretty that's
just like january i mean if you
systematically
got feeling like i've seen the fake ones
before and this one definitely doesn't
seem like the fake one just a lot of
them where it's like
sad music royalty three and then oh yeah
crack
crackhead no you know you know if
there's like
[ __ ] like sad music in the background
it's probably [ __ ] scripted right
it's like you must feel sad now because
of the sad music it's not even
it's it's it's also like the sad music
you know they've gone from the youtube
library because it's you've heard it a
million times
on like other channels i see you're also
using kevin macleod
like i was i was going i was in the
shopping mall the other day
and i i was i was walking past like um
like this makeup section
and they were using that [ __ ] ukulele
that [ __ ] ukulele youtube stock music
that's my favorite piece of music just
because i i can envision
every video that usually yeah it's like
wait it's like
it's like way too like [ __ ] white the
white balance is just completely off
it's like way too bright way too sunny
the background is way too clean and it
always starts with
hey guys today's my outfit of the day
yeah i'm like i i i look back to that
period and just think
why why ukulele why why did why did
every vlogger ha at one point
you can't be sad listening to a ukulele
right like you can't you
do you guys like report of the week did
you guys
he is like in a league of his own in
terms of content there's like i i
i also think of him as like a category
of creator yeah like
i can often compare creators to him in
the sense of like that's the kind of
charm that they have
well what other creators do you think
are like i was i was about to say like
buff corral i wanted to shout out
my boy buff carrel like okay how do you
describe buff carrel
as a channel it is just you can never
like leave one of his videos not being
happy yeah like
just a guy like literally buff carl
that's his name he's puff
yeah he dances and sings his singing is
horrible but in such an endearing and
funny way that like you love it
because the boy can dance [ __ ] dance
and he's buff as [ __ ] as well i'm like
i love this one the first time you watch
any of his videos everyone goes on the
same trip
where like he starts dancing you're like
okay this place you can dance
pause this video and go and watch that
video right now and then he opens his
mouth
and it's just like the [ __ ] worst
singing you've ever heard
but then he does it with such
self-confidence
that you're like damn man i can only
respect you know what he is he's the
epitome of like
this is what i do in my room when i'm
alone but i decided to get a camera
and start recording myself so he's so
happy dude yeah like you're just like
man i love it it's [ __ ] it's so
infectious like my dream
is to one day have a [ __ ] karaoke
sesh with buffalo
please buff girl come to japan we'll
have you in trash taste and go to a
karaoke sesh
that is like my [ __ ] dream
like that that is that is on like my
[ __ ] list of things to do before i
die
and i love as well like the little
easter eggs he throws around like the
fact that he has a picture of himself
yeah
i love that it's so interesting and the
fact that the camera quality is like the
same [ __ ]
low hd [ __ ] five pixel cameras like
the thing i love is that like he's not
even pointing the camera at himself he's
pointing it at a mirror
that has a reflection on here epic dude
it's
like cinematography that's the thing
right it's like it's it's channels like
that like him and like report of the
week where it's like
i don't care if this is a joke or if
they're being 100 serious i'd still
answer
i can't i like i would be impressed if
they were putting that on yeah because
there's there's no way
that that kind of genuine can like like
happiness
cannot like radiate but it's the age-old
question right like with report of the
week like
is that actually how he is or is he just
doing this joke i'm happy
yeah i i don't want to know you know all
right right but like that's like kind of
like half the fun i love the memes
i love the memes but it's it's kind of
just kind of like this content creator
who i
i feel like they're just being
themselves but part of their personality
is so [ __ ] infectious that you cannot
watch a video and not come out happier
yeah i mean i could be having the
shittest day
yeah put on a buff corral video i'm like
okay
how can i be sad when he's not sad you
know what i mean
how can i be having pulling off these
sick moves
dude twitter is the most like blessed
cursed thing i've ever
seen because like i think like three
times a day he posts a selfie of himself
hell with like no captions
it's the most like it's it's like a dude
who just loves himself so much but you
can't hate him for it
i love that i love it it's like you have
so much self-confidence
yeah and man i respect because it's just
like it's it's
i i can't like quantify into words but
like what is
what is the line between like vanity and
self-confidence and buff carell
like he he [ __ ] obliterates that liar
because he's so
vain yet you just you just feel happy
for him there's
no negative feelings right it's just
it's just ugh